welcome to this video play the cross
shark again hell no the you came and yep
let's play another of those Jack zip
lines yeah and it's I'm really amazed
how many players some went away I go for
go for this setup which is really just
bad and it's a it's well known since i
bought Vinny kappa blanca that this is
just a bad setup still it gets it gets
played very often what yeah this is this
is very weird giving giving up here the
dark squares I'm telling with you for
and Bishop g5 yeah what that's the
central at sheer and Bishop g5 coming
maybe 96 96 intending 95 hmm don't tell
me that this trick is working ok so I
cannot go go in here because of night
green 24 check so this is also possibly
queen edge form and thus 95 okay so we
need Shaw is not threatening okay let's
let's place the bishop here the long
diagonal with g6 being played cannot be
too bad for this for the bishop I'm
threatening queena three now as defaults
protected and maybe there are some ideas
to just go d5 queen deform and then
lining up for Queen g7 mate it's very
tricky for black fighting against the
complete centers always a problem at
some they are very very rare occasions
well you can give the opponent of fruit
call center and still be ok even in
openings like the groom felt you usually
have a porn on e6 or something you don't
have a and D pawn against nothing okay
yeah just a general move but what is
what what are you doing on queen of
three
just f6 hanging and g14 yes but on h3
night h6 problem and no here Queen f6
twin f6 is a monstrous threat
yeah and Queen Queen f6 and Queen sorry
resigned yeah Quincy 3 says the next
move and this is this is a very very big
check on a jade yeah this is pretty much
the kind of game that can easily happen
if black guy goes for the g5 setup oops
this kind of position is already em now
he's he's doing that yeah it's always a
shout analysis Wharton hmm um I was just
okay then let's not move I was just
trying to say that this kind of center
is really a questionable for black so if
at all you you can try to operate with
moves like h5 h4 after 93 it serve some
very m tricky to play and if you're not
100-percent precise you get exactly the
kind of position as mentioned in the
game however however i played Queen d3
here it's a dozen briefly check them
because he's always going to the end of
the game this is really annoying here I
was thinking maybe night to e6 was an
option attacking you form yeah I can
also just played if I have to be honest
295 Queen d4 Knight takes and Bishop g2
where they cannot survive that the
computer actually already gives us as a
winning position yeah it's too much this
is a maybe yeah probably even then it's
not playable what g6 is really the name
in the move that makes it the win
without g6 but without g6 that's not a 5
coming in some way yeah playing against
to mobile incentive bonuses it's not
fun very often it's just straight losing
alright thanks for watching